in the manosphere there are two sims but
I'm gonna focus on the first one there
is the king of simps they call him and I
personally didn't know who he was but I
found out about him his name's Derek
Jackson okay oh dear
um I want to know what you guys know of
Derek Jackson and what what is your
opinion on him I just know he tries to
be the motivation of like helping women
and giving them advice and doing this
and doing that but he ended up cheating
on his wife and then exposed it to the
world yeah and she was on the side just
looking stupid too so I mean that's the
most on I haven't seen all his videos
but I've seen a few but that was I think
that was enough
I used to watch a lot of his videos
because he would be on Instagram and I'd
be like oh some of the stuff that he's
saying it sounds good so I followed him
and seeing like where when he did she on
his wife is like you think back to his
videos and it's just like sir when you
were in that car were you leaving or
were you going are you you were telling
on yourself the whole time you're like
men if you don't like your wife if she
looks like this she looks like that you
need to do this if you don't like being
with her how are you going to cheat on
them and then go back to him it's just
like but you did it how are you going to
tell the people not to do it and you did
it can I ask how did it come out but he
uh
remember I think I mean the girl made
the woman might have done an exposed it
or something no the the side chick oh
yeah yeah I think she exposed it does
anyone in the chat know how it came out
um I I know it was like
she was like a doctor or something and I
remember he got her pregnant
and my finger was a couple one
but yeah oh wow he was hitting it wrong
you know what that reminds me of a like
touch pastors and stuff unfortunately
that like revealed to have like
prostitutes and oh the one in New York
because they're they're the homemakers
yeah
because that's why they preach like
forgiveness for the hoes so they can
really compose
they should baptize you
I feel like it's okay we preach
forgiveness here he's like marketing
he's like come to my church yeah
um but um I have a clip from him that
we're gonna watch and I just want to get
you guys take on it
um someone said it was Tasha K was the
one who Okay side chick um Tasha K put
him on class and the side chick exposed
him okay I could see that happen here
yeah I don't really know who I've heard
the name Tasha K I don't really know who
she is she's in problems with cardi B
yeah she needs to chill she just got
sued by having it yeah oh did she really
a lot as well a lot of money sheesh
because she's in everybody's business
no this is another one no this is a
YouTuber yeah it's just like okay okay
she's in everybody's business and she
exposed him and then the woman came out
ah okay
yeah yeah ready
team Jackson what's happening you know
after looking at my comments and seeing
these guys that be getting the arguments
with y'all I've noticed something
reverse psychology is ain't [ __ ] man's
best friend
really anything that's supposed to make
you feel bad for him not being on your
level like it don't matter what he says
it all means he can't handle you I'll
give you some examples you tell me if
you heard him before like say you
watching something on TV and you tell
them your thoughts about it and then you
ask him what his are and he says
something like man you thinking way too
much into it I am not talking about
y'all to be getting legit mad at a man
for some hypothetical [ __ ] that never
happened but if you just try to have a
conversation beyond the surface level he
responds with that he can't handle your
thought process like it should be at
least able to articulate his thoughts as
to why he feels that way but if that's
how he ends every conversation you try
to start that means mentally he's not on
your level and he's blaming you for it
oh here's another one whenever he's been
doing some suspect [ __ ] so you ask him
about it that way you don't overreact
and he responds with you know what you
acting real insecure right now like how
secure are you supposed to be when his
actions are things that could breach
security now when the dude says that
that means he wants you to question your
judgment about something y'all both know
is blurring the line
like if you notice all of a sudden that
your dude is changing his passcode every
few days or deleting text messages or
pressing ignore on Late Night Calls
you're supposed to ask about that it's
just like whenever you log into your
online banking from a new device it asks
you further questions to verify your
identity not because you're doing
something wrong but they want to make
sure that you're not so when you ask a
dude about a new friend girl that you
ain't never met or any of his actions
that make you raise her eyebrow that's
not you being insecure that you
verifying his identity that he's not a
[ __ ] boy another thing he'll say when he
can't handle you it's like whenever he
tried to pop up on you without prior
notice or invite you over to his house
but you not having it so he says you
ain't even giving me a chance but what
he really means is it ain't got nothing
to do with you not giving him a chance
it just means he can't handle the amount
of effort you require for a man to stand
a chance
I go to the gym all the time and see
dudes trying to lift weights they ain't
got no business trying to lift and it's
not that the weights won't give them a
chance they just don't have what it
takes to put forth the amount of effort
that's required for that weight sad part
is some guys will tell a woman that
she's not giving him a chance and she'll
actually make herself lighter instead of
telling him he needs to either get his
weight up or go to some weight that he
can handle
no you need to make the effort required
to get close to you not up for
negotiation because in that case the
only chance that you're not giving is
one to a man who's trying to waste your
time oh here's one want to do it invites
you out to a ratchet ass Hood spot and
you give them a better suggestion or
he's texting you with [ __ ] grammar so
you clarify what he means and he says so
you think you all that
actually it's about all that he means
you don't want to go places frequently
about 40 year olds SoundCloud rappers
that never made it and you prefer
coherent sentences in your conversations
then he might be right but you know what
you should think that you're all
laughing and you should entertain a man
who thinks the same instead of dudes who
tell you that you wrong for the level of
quality you want and how you spend your
time and communicate with them all right
I'll give y'all one more example like
when the dude says see all that you want
from a man that's unrealistic [ __ ]
thinking like that you're gonna stay
single
now I made a video about this but it's
worth mentioning again when a guy says
that he means that he and men like him
can't handle the value that you expect
in return in a relationship so you
should feel bad about it but the problem
is in order for women to believe that
they have to believe that all men are as
tired as this guy is and there are too
many examples that prove otherwise
especially for women that were raised by
Good Men they have siblings or family
members that are good men that go to
church with good men they've befriended
good men or they got friends who were
found by good men like there are simply
too many good Brothers out here for
these ain't [ __ ] dudes to keep promoting
themselves as the mascot for all men or
the definition of what's realistic so
please don't go for it so if a dude
tells you anything that essentially
translates to he can't handle you
because he's not on your level leave him
on his and find you a man that's on your
level so you two can go to the next one
together
so this was his most viewed video oh
really yeah so is this recent no it's
not this is
um I think it's older but what do you
guys think
Derek Derek Derek go ahead King isn't it
so ironic that you were saying all these
things you was obviously talking about
yourself
Derek you cheated on your wife you was
probably cheating on your wife when you
made that video like I find it amazing
that you have the confidence to come out
in your car with your little dry fit
vest talking about oh a guy can't handle
you if he says this if he says that bro
those are lines out of your playbook bro
what are you talking about
bro like this is just crazy and really
and truly any woman that follows Derek
Jackson you're just gullible and just
dumb yeah I'm saying at the end of the
day this guy is just he's just pandering
and simping for the affection and the
attention of gullible desperate women at
the end of the day it's just he's just
selling you not a dream he couldn't even
sell his own wife a dream because he got
exposed but like it's a joke in it he
talks like a girl he talks like a [ __ ]
really and truly and he he never says
anything like advocating for guys and
he's talking about oh um find you a guy
and and there's all good guys out there
but you're not one of them Derek
like what are you talking about like
this guy's just annoying bro like he
just gets me heated in it because at the
end of the day he's trying to sell a
dream he and he's not even that dream
himself the only reason he gets played
and a lot of women like to listen to him
is because they probably are attracted
to him and find him attractive that's
that's literally it he's saying what
these women want to hear they're
gullible and he's six foot four he's
built like an NFL tight end so obviously
boom that's it and he's got money so in
their eyes he's a high value man and
even when he got found out for
fornicating on his wife who had a child
for him that like he's still got a
following so I just find this to be a
quite amazing to be honest I don't know
what you love thinks but anyway I think
he's corny he gives advice that he can't
take and when he talks he sounds like
he's talking about his personal stuff
and he sounds like he's overly trying to
be convincing
so his voice to me doesn't sound
authentic you know like it's quite
scripted like he's trying to convince
you of what he's saying too much it just
doesn't come across like he's speaking
from the heart so he always kind of
seemed corny to me anyway do you know
what I mean so yeah
um but in when you first when you first
came across Derek Jackson did you think
he was corny or did you think no I like
what you're saying because I think a lot
of women they a lot of women did like
what he said initially because it kind
of feeds into how you like some of the
things that he's saying you know it's
like the message is there but I don't
know it's like he can't deliver it in
the right way to me I can see that he's
a narcissist even before he got caught
because he's talked so much I think he
over kills it when he's trying to
explain something he's speaking so much
because he loves camera time he he
speaks to women so much because that's
who he wants to attract he's not
speaking to men because he doesn't want
men in his DMS he wants women oh yeah
the attention of women that's why he's
so trying to yeah he's like the pastor
yeah he wants not all part not all
pastors but I know that yeah but um yeah
that's that's what I get her from him
and men will call him out anyway yeah
exactly that's what I was going to say
yeah and he so he deliberately he's just
like okay I'm gonna go here because
they'll just believe what whatever I'm
gonna say the small man will that he was
talking about
like the chicken shop or the taco shop
that the 40 year olds are I'm like where
what type of guys do you guys date like
I'm just confused
I just find I just find it to be a joke
really and like no one should ever take
him seriously and anyone that does take
him seriously brother don't be surprised
if your life goes to ruin brother his
wife stayed with him though didn't she
and she said in my opinion she's silly
for that at first um they got divorced
oh they did oh I didn't know that
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna double check
but I swear but think about the
psychology of that though think about
the psychology of him like he's spewing
all of this rhetoric and cheating
now it's not even like he's going in
general he's going straight at the guys
you guys and these women deserve better
blah blah blah what about your own wife
bro exactly you're talking about that's
usually how they tell on themselves
because they can't stop talking about it
yeah so it's like they're trying to
cover their tracks in a way and when you
can with somebody that was giving out so
much advice you know like if you claim
to be such a perfect man in the perfect
relationship and that you're supposed to
can look at somebody's wife and just
instantly tell that she's happy she just
looks so tired in that but if she looks
higher than that
do you understand like she was so tired
of him would you get what I mean you
know it didn't even look like somebody
that said okay we're human he's made a
mistake and I'm standing by my husband
it wasn't even that she did he just
looked like he constantly uses um
Mind Games to just tear her down to make
her feel like she needs him did you
understand what I mean those are the
type of men that just
um eat away at your um self-confidence
to get me can you imagine like being in
her shoes where I mean because I doubt
that was the first time she caught him
cheating oh like I'm sure it was I'm
sure it happened more than once and just
listening to your husband like do these
talks I was just gonna say yeah that's
mine that makes it ten thousand times
worse
I just can't think like oh my God she
probably thinks he's so full of [ __ ]
because she knows all of it that's what
I'm saying the psychology behind it is
mad like do you get what I'm saying like
so
yeah man he's just full of crap to be
honest like he's a joke in my opinion
the funny thing is he's still making
money from his little talks and
everything other people are still
listening to him after all the stuff
that he's done sorry so hold on okay so
women don't want to get cheated on but
they're following a man who says the
right things who cheated on his wife
because then women don't want to accept
accountability yeah and he's in the
right package
he's tall he's big he's got money
there you go because like let's keep it
real the majority of his audience are
the type of women that would be
attracted to a guy like that
specifically do you get what I'm saying
so that's easy that's that's a monopoly
straight away now yeah he probably lost
some of his fan base boom boom boom but
there's gonna be some that well you know
well you know give him a second chance
see this is this is the thing they're
never consistent
the outrage with like they're never
consistent they're always like you know
if you find something consistently bad
will be no matter what happens if a
family member does it or somebody but
they always kind of change it make
excuses and everything for whoever you
like yeah makes excuses for whoever you
like
yeah as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible